في قسم الطوارئ حاليا قبل الحرب كانت سعه
مستشفى غزه الاوروبي عدد الاسره في
الطوارئ حوالي 14 سرير بالاضافه الى ثلاث
اسره عنايه حاليا انا صباحا مريت على في
قسم الباطنه لدينا حوالي 16 مريض
فقط فقط داخل الطوارئ لحالهم غير
الموجودين في المستشفى يعني عدد مرضى
الباطنه في قسم الطوارئ المنومين او
المرقدين داخل اقسام المستشفى اكثر من
السعه السريريه هنالك يعني في حوالي
تقريبا معي مض مريضتين مريت عليهم كانوا
على الارض بدون بدون فراش بدون سرير حتى
هذا في قسم الطوارئ فما بالك في باقي
الاقسام الموجوده في المستشفى طبعا ناهيك
عن غياب ونقص كبير في الاعداد والكوادر
الطبيه طبعا نتيجه التغييب هناك عدد كبير
نتيجه تغييب حوالي في 100 كادر من الكوادر
الطبيه تم اعتقالهم عند العدو الصهيوني
الساعات الصباح الاولى ما بين الساعه
السبعه لبين الساعه تقريبا الثانيه ظهرا
يعني انك تكون تلاقي لك 10 سم في طوارئ
فاضي فهذا نعمه الاستقبال والطوارئ هو خط
الدفاع الاول في الجنوب وتقريبا مستشفى
غزه الاوروبي المستشفى الحيد اللي بغطي في
الجنوب طبعا عننا اكاز كبير في عدد
الحالات حيث ان نغطي حالات الدخول حالات
الاصابات حالات البيات عننا احنا في قسم
الاستقبال على مدار الساعه الحالات
متواجده بسبب عدم اتساع الاسره في
المستشفى طبعا عننا حالات جراحه حالات
باطنه حالات عظام بنشوف جميع انواع
الحالات في قسم الاستبدال بعد الشفا
والاندونيسي والماني وحتى مستشفى ناصر
مستشفى الاقصى اصبح المستشفى الاوروبي هو
المستشفى الوحيد الذي يعمل وبقدرات محدوده
مما ادى ذلك الى نزوح الاهالي من الشمال
ومن الجنوب ومن الوسط الى مستشفى الغروب
الى الاوروبي ادى الى اكتظاظ المرضى
واكتظاظ الناس ادى ذلك الى تاخير في
العمليات الجراحيه على مدار 24 ساعه بشتغل
الخمس غرف بتكون شغاله على مدار ال 24
ساعه بنكون واقفين في غرف العمليات
تقريبا اكثر من 14 ساعه وفي بصير احداث
بصير قصف نلغي العمليات المجدوله وبنشتغل
في العمليات
الطارقه